hey youtubers is Charlie arrow just came
back from Olympics hiatus and wasted no
time in picking up the pace we got a lot
more River Song we got Robert Knepper
playing a character from the comic books
there were two major plot points that
were paid off and we got some of the
best felicity scenes that I've seen all
season seriously this was really her
episode quick shut up for the flash
spinoff they're shooting the pilot next
week in Vancouver so I'm gonna wait to
do a video till then hopefully there'll
be a lot of good behind the scenes
pictures be sure to subscribe to get
that video I'm still posting my regular
Q&A video tomorrow just like normal
though since there were so many good
things in the episode let's do our top
five moments then I'll do all the comic
book references and then I'll do my
review careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet but number
five Oliver and Sarah go everywhere
together now the funniest part of this
is that Harry's own daughter is standing
right in front of him in Black Canary
costume and he still doesn't know who
they are I love that Oliver even
referred to himself in third person this
is totally gonna keep happening then
piling around town together hopefully
for the rest of this season and into
season 3 number 4 Felicity training
session what are you wearing Emily BETT
Rickards actually said that she's not
jealous of Oliver and Sara in a
traditional way but she is upset at the
thought of losing the closeness that
they have it's pretty clear that Sara
saw through all this and since they're
destined to become the birds of prey I'm
actually really looking forward to how
they deal with it
I'm sure Felicity will get through it
with plenty of wushu and punching it's
really just fun to see her get some
action away from her computer console it
would have been a little bit more fun if
she was wearing Batgirl colors just
because the show is implying that in the
birds-of-prey trio she's going to be the
Oracle character number three all of the
stunts most notably during the climax at
the bank
Oliver sliding down staircases backwards
while shooting arrows Felicity taking a
bullet midair while blowing up clock
King James Bamford is the stunt
coordinator so he's actually responsible
for all the awesome fight scenes
you may remember his work from Stargate
Atlantis he is the reason Jason Momoa
got all those awesome fight scenes
number two Felicity vs. Sara the blood
analysis was just the most fun part of
the Felicity vs. Sara story arc I felt
so bad for when it seemed like Sara
scienced her into submission but that
look on her face will live on and tumblr
infamy forever I will say that Felicity
did get the last laugh she saved Sara
took the boat from her and was still
worried that she had killed the clock
King it says the writers wanted to be a
badass without compromising her morals
or getting really vicious like Sarah and
my number one moment
drunk Felicity naked speechifying
everyone run for cover because this
totally made tumblr explode it's amazing
to see how the show damages their
relationship and then puts it back
together in an instant I can't wait to
see the outtake reel from this scene
just the part where she fumbles over her
words I would like to thank Diggle and I
would like to thank oxycotin for this
wonderful performance somebody needs to
give Felicity a drunk Oscar it's like
the normal Oscars but they're only four
performances given while you're drunk
and one last bonus moment Slade reveals
himself publicly he's not hiding or
appearing to Green Arrow first he went
to Moira probably to get involved with
her run for mayor he's really just
letting Oliver know that he can kill
them at any moment the teaser for the
next episode featured scenes that pick
up directly where this scene left off so
we won't have to wait long to find out
what that quote-unquote promise between
them is but now it's your turn let me
know what was your favorite moment I
know I know we're all thinking the same
thing you'll always be my girl it's too
much it's just too much here are all the
comic book references that I saw though
there are a couple important ones
starting with cord industries this was
where William tockman the clock King
worked
they mentioned cord industries in so
many different episodes including grant
gustin's flash episodes that I'm
wondering if they're laying groundwork
for Ted Kord to guest star on the show
in season 3 and then eventually
hopefully the Blue Beetle
then there was Sarah's bar oblivion this
is the home base of shadow pact and it
exists in this pocket dimension that
overlaps with several other universes so
it's like a nexus of the multiverse
where you can grab a drink and hire a
magic user next up was Alex Kingston
talking about being a history professor
in Central City and having another man
the easy one is obviously the River Song
reference meaning that the other man
could totally be the doctor and Central
City is where the flash show will take
place so her character could also be a
backdoor to bring arrow people onto the
show overall I gave the episode a solid
a - just for amazing use of Emily BETT
Rickards
and for paying off the sin and Slade
storylines they've been teasing a
villains arc on the show that's going to
start soon and we'll cross four or five
episodes for a show that has to fill an
hour of time every week it has 23
episodes per season arrow does such an
amazing job of weaving in new characters
and side stories to keep it feel
fresh to be fair to other shows like
Supernatural I mean it's been around for
nine years so I don't expect the same
things from it the only thing that felt
out of place in this episode was Thea it
did feel like if you had cut her lines
then nothing about the story would have
changed even that call to Oliver at the
end felt like it was either Slade
hacking her phone or something that the
writers created purely as a reason to
get him in the house when Slade was
there let me know what you thought about
the episode though but like I said next
week you know hopefully there'll be some
awesome flash behind the scenes stuff
I'll be posting my regular Q&A tomorrow
- be sure to subscribe to get everything
I've also got a ton of other videos that
I'm posting this weekend so between now
and Sunday I'll be posting a special
South Park stick of truth giveaway that
I'm going to be doing this week's
supernatural and a super fun game of
Thrones video that will cover stuff all
the way back to season one right now
click here for my last episode of arrow
game click here for that Q&A video
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight high fives
you